[Music]
welcome back to CBS Saturday morning we
begin this half hour with a
centuries-old tradition in danger of
being lost since 1965 the number of
Catholic nuns and monks in the United
States has fallen by 79 percent it's a
signal of increasingly secular views
among Americans three in ten adults in
the U.S now say they're religiously
unaffiliated as more and more
monasteries close some including one
overlooking the entertainment capital of
the world are trying to find a way
forward
just below the Hollywood sign a few
blocks up the street from Sunset
Boulevard there's a place that stands in
contradiction to Hollywood welcome to
Monastery of the Angel the monastery of
the Angels were sister Maria Christine
invited us in may we so we certainly can
is cloistered rooted in a 13th century
religious tradition founded in France by
a monk named Dominique Guzman this is
the home of the nuns and normally the
public is never allowed in here I.E me
you and all of my friends all of your
friends as you notice there's no
doorknob so from the public side you
can't enter for most of the past 99
years Dominican nuns have lived here and
rarely stepped off Monastery property
that's really four acres of prime
Hollywood real estate donated by a
copper Tycoon we keep silence most of
the day we'll eat in common refactor
everything is in common this is when you
need the sisters you can
[Music]
they would ring this in order to call
the sisters to prayer because as a Clay
Street nuns we would come to choir to
Chapel seven times a day for prayers
this is within the heart of Hollywood
and you don't hear a thing do you not a
thing a thing the quiet Stillness has
long been noticed nonetheless by
neighbors who have been allowed to visit
the limited public parts of the
monastery even movie stars became
Monastery regulars like who
well we had famous people like Jane
Wyman Doris Day Bob and Dolores hope
Bing Crosby and Hollywood really
supported this space they did they just
it was their escape they'd come over
here to just have that quiet prayerful
recollection so the sister said we are
here to pray for Hollywood we're here to
pray for the movie industry for the
morality imagine how that went well
you know
you could say a prayer can move
mountains
but sometimes you have mountains that
you can't move very well
you pray for Hollywood
and yet it's still Halloween it's still
Hollywood
yeah what do I say Hollywood and the
nuns found many ways to embrace each
other special Showbiz relics ended up
with the sisters for safekeeping for
example this piano was used to compose
Rogers and Hammerstein's musical
Oklahoma
and when Jane Wyman was not winning the
Oscar for best actress she made sure
another statue Grace the grounds where
the sisters prayed but prayers and
famous benefactors can't pay all the
bills life as it has been known here has
ended the sisters all moved to other
monasteries but vocations aren't
plentiful like they used to be and we
saw our aging numbers escalating and not
the young so there was a gap in between
and we said we can be more useful by
supporting our other monasteries and
then repurposing our Monastery here I
would imagine there are quite a few real
estate speculators who would love to get
their hands on this property oh yes yes
I have a whole box full of letters that
I've received makes us very unique but
sister Maria Christine isn't selling the
monastery of the Angels is more than
just a fabulous piece of land with
special touches the exercise room the
dear benefactor said you know we need to
put a pool in here where the sisters can
exercise properly this is quite a gift
isn't this or is it 10 decades of
memories left in Sister Maria
Christine's care there's centuries of a
religious practice to preserve somehow
and back here was the sewing room gone
is the sewing room where sisters made
vestments we also would make rosaries
can you teach me they won't be making
rosary beads here anymore either like
that
maybe we have here to get you to
knitting instead of crocheting
so what is the plan the plan is probably
still in the eyes of God we have many
people with many ideas
some of it has to do with a more
professional health care
or is it a school so this is the bakery
one thing sure to be preserved is the
pumpkin bread with the sister's own
special recipe delicious a popular
commodity that's still being baked sold
and since the pandemic shipped all
across the country
as for the valuable property the
Dominicans are not letting it go and are
determined that the monastery of the
Angel's future be very much like its
past a place under the sign that strives
to make Hollywood a better place in its
own deliberately quiet way
was amazing so it's super interesting
and I brought pumpkin bread back food I
buy food it's delicious please taste I I
just you know I I couldn't help myself
or help to think that sister Maria
Christine is like holding back on maybe
what the real plan is isil got her she
just mums the words no it's Eyes Of God
I mean she's um was really interesting
find out although my favorite part was
Michelle says it's all about quiet
reflection and she's like can I ring
this Bell
y that's the strongest suit there